>>Hi, I'm Chris O'Neal, and we're
going to do a brief tour of YouTube.
I think of YouTube as, like,
a giant video flea market.
So lots of cool finds mixed
in with a lot of crazy junk.
From a teacher's standpoint,
it's a treasure trove of videos,
so let's take a quick tour.
We're going to start off by going to
YouTube.com, and on the main page,
what you'll find is just a variety
of most popular clips of the day,
the most talked about
clip of the week.
Just like you wouldn't set your
students free on a field trip,
though, without giving them
some guidance ahead of time,
you probably shouldn't sit
students down in front of YouTube,
and have them search
aimlessly, either.
Whatever your thoughts on YouTube
may be, it makes the most sense
to give age appropriate
guidance to your kids.
There's certainly a lot to learn
from watching YouTube videos.
Some of the content is just
not appropriate for all ages.
I'm going to start off by doing
the most common thing on YouTube,
which is just a basic search.
I'm going to click here,
and type, life cycle,
since that's something a
lot of teachers look for.
What you'll find are
thousands of video returns.
It tells me right here, 9,400 videos
have been uploaded to YouTube,
that use the words, life cycle.
I got lucky, in that the first
clip I click on right here,
will start playing automatically.
I'm going to pause it, is
actually about the life cycle
of the lunar moth, so that's
perfect for what I'm looking for.
You'll find that searching
ahead of time is the key
to making efficient use of
YouTube in the classroom.
So now that I've found a
great video I'd like to use,
I can either show it right away--
I'm just going to click play,
to show the video, or I
can embed it to show it
in my own website, blog or wiki.
If you look to the right of the
video, you'll see a brief description
of the video, which is provided by
the person who uploaded this video.
Directly beneath the description
is the URL for this video,
so I can e-mail this URL to someone
else, and let them watch the video.
Directly beneath that
is an embed section.
If I click in that white
horizontal bar, I get embed code,
which means I can copy that text,
and paste it into a wiki or a blog,
or website, and actually embed the
video directly into my own website.
Beneath this embed code section
are a few options you'll want
to pay attention to.
The first box that says,
include related videos,
I always uncheck that box.
If you don't uncheck that box, and
you embed your video, you'll find,
to the side, some extra videos
that YouTube suggests, which may,
or may not be appropriate for what
you want to share with your children.
So I uncheck this box.
I choose a size that I
like, and then I click back
up in the embed code section,
right click, and copy.
Now I simply go to my wiki or
blog, and paste in that text.
You can create your
own account on YouTube
which allows you to save favorites.
I'm logged in right now.
I can look at my videos, my
favorites, I can even make playlists.
I can subscribe to specific
sections of YouTube,
specific users or even
tag or keywords.
I can also be alerted when
users I like upload new videos.
The newest section to YouTube
that I think teachers
like, is YouTube.com/edu.
That's an education
section of YouTube,
built specifically for educators.
The videos uploaded
in the section are
from universities and school systems.
Each of these videos is provided
with the notion that they can be
of some help to teachers.
So the users who create these videos
agree that all videos uploaded
to this specific section,
have education in mind.
Last, but most certainly not least,
you can upload your
own videos to YouTube.
Whether you've shot
vacation video footage,
or you've even staged a video,
because you know it will be helpful
to other teachers, it's a
great place to share video.
Not only do you get to
catalogue your own video
for your specific classrooms, but
other people around the world get
to make use of your video as well.
Be sure to visit www.edutopia.org,
for more educational resources.